peace be with you
Salaam alaikum welcome to the D show we
have an exciting episode for you today
love yes but is that the love of
Hollywood or is it the love of Bollywood
what's this fantasy that you have in
your mind and when you get married it
all explodes it all goes in the wrong
direction we're here today to talk about
so many different things the simplicity
of the nakiya when two people come
together the right way to please their
creator and they come together to
fulfill half of their Deen in marriage
so it doesn't break we're gonna be
talking about how to keep it together
and how to get mature enough so you can
engage in one of the most important
commitments that's right
marriage to do it the right way not the
wrong way so get your note book that
take some notes we have the professor
from love notes here with us
shake your bridges to cover this very
important topic here on the Dean show
don't go anywhere
this is the you're still doing the the
people still taking notes at the love
notes
that's one of the most successful
classes a lot of color that I've been
teaching so far
so a lot of people are getting a benefit
and we want our viewers to benefit from
your advice your experiences and the
things that you're out there because
this seminar is something that you
conducted the L Maghrib right and this
is some weekend seminars it's actually
one weekend seminar
it's it's a full weekend you could say
workshop or I'd call it personally
life-changing experience I don't call it
class I don't call it lecture it's
actually our life-changing experience
because truly when people come in they
come with a lot of wrong assumptions
perception about marriage but the moment
they come and step into that class from
that from the first session until the
end every time there is something new
that they're learning is something that
it changes their way of thinking about
it and I've heard that for many many
students who come to this class that
when they leave they just basically say
you know what this class I really
changed completely the way I see raised
in my views on marriage now let's put
things in perspective because like most
of the we're obviously impacted by the
culture around us really the culture
around us is pushing off marriage a
little more into dating you know hanging
out you know it's living it's not a lot
lifestyle so how do we get people more
in tune with what we're actually talking
about when people are like why why all
the responsibility on why can't I just
have a girlfriend boyfriend and marriage
is something you know maybe if I get 50
40 this is this is very ironic because
you would never think that the Muslim
community which is considered a very
conservative community that would get to
this point basically when it comes to
marriage it's becoming right now an
absolute thing almost
not so many people are enthusiastic
about marriage as it used to be in the
past and when I asked a young young men
and women today about their views on
marriage and when do they see themselves
married and so forth many of them they
kind of shake their heads I just like
they're now they're delaying it and they
keep saying what happens if allah
subhanho their walls and so and so so
when you ask them why exactly that the
letter marriages you hear all these all
these assumptions about the meaning of
marriage and the responsibilities they
expecting from the relationship so
they're kind of they're freaking out
they're really getting the wrong the
wrong assumption about marriage it seems
that the rate of divorce as it goes high
in the Muslim community it sends the
wrong signal to the people so many of
them they kind of shunning the idea of
getting married and they keep pushing it
as far as they could hoping that they
will become ready for it emotionally
mentally whatever financially and so on
but in the process as they do that they
also put so much pressure on themselves
because again culturally people they see
a young lady for example a young guy at
an age that they expect to be married
and the question that comes so why
aren't you married yet so there is so
much acting so much pressure on them
hence when it comes to college
specifically in college many students
they want to spend some time again maybe
they're serious or genuine about getting
married or maybe just fantasizing until
they finished school so then they get
married afterwards how important is it
now in in Islam to get married to really
be mature in a mature state of mind that
you're really because we know as half of
our Deen when we say it's half of our
Deen why talk about the importance of
really you know focusing on this
important part of your Deen as a matter
of fact allah subhanho wa taala in sort
of the room he mentioned he mentioned
that the value of love and mercy which
is basically the basis of any
relationship any marriage we didn't the
count as a miracle within the context of
speaking about a lot of miracles from
the creation of allah subhana wa ta'ala
Allah was speaking about the creation of
man the creation of the heavens and the
earth actually the creation of the rain
and the alteration of the day and night
and so on and in the middle a lot of
Hanukah racism in ayah
kubinashi comas waha and among his sign
is this and he has created for you from
amongst yourselves as Waja means spouses
partners here and he says let us could
find peace and tranquility with them
well J alibi nakumo data wa rahma and he
plays between your heart mawatha and
rama means love and mercy or passion and
compassion in a politically i had
definitely there are science for those
who reflect the cumulative occur on so a
logical mentioned the word science twice
over here that is one of the greatest
miracles of the creation of a large L is
a creation of man and woman so they can
get together in matrimony so they can
have peace and tranquility with each
other or at least that's what they're
supposed to strive for and a lot of her
to make it easy for them he placed love
and mercy in their heart so that's
natural there are a lot great us too
inclined towards you know getting
married towards finding a partner for
ourselves in life that's part of the
Sunnah of a lots of heart Alice creation
the prophets of Allah sensing this the
the significance of that he encouraged
people he said the Amish are Sheba - Oh
Tom and convey filitosa which he's
speaking to the unnamed people saying
that whoever is actually is capable of
getting married he says do let him do so
but of course now this is when the
context of of your culture back then
getting mad was very simple and easy the
demands that marriage until from people
back there was not as many as as they
are today so some people they try to
take the course the idealism of that
time perhaps when it comes to marriage
and try to project this today and by
passing a lot of essential things that
would make the relationship successful
especially the younger generation being
hasty and rushing into things you just
want to get married in any way you just
want to get married do you think that
most marriages they they collapse they
don't end up becoming fruitful because
the reference point usually as I open
the show is Hollywood in Bollywood
actually there are two honestly there
are two points of references that we
have and that's surprise basically when
people want to put Center you have to
put it between two poles sometimes we
take it pretty to extremes so the pole
or the center becomes a little bit off
where it's supposed to happen so some
people they they want to make their
marriage like a fairy tale Hollywood
style
Bollywood star whatever and others they
want to make their marriage completely
come
really as if it's like you know from the
time of the prophet sallallaahu Selim
which is the sooner that we need to
follow of course there's no doubt about
it but not taking the culture of that
time in in consideration how easy it was
how simple things were the demands for
magic were less of course than the
others today
so either way if they try to have an
ideal relationship an ideal form of
marriage it might fail in the
contemporary context of our lives and
also if they would like to take
completely a fairy tale style which only
exists in movies and even realities and
they will also fail so people just go to
extremes
they don't take things in the right
context we're gonna take a break shake
and we come back a lot more to ask you
on this very important topic here in the
Dean show with Shaikh gossiper just
don't go anywhere please subscribe to
the video follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and I hope you're
taking notes love notes that's the class
you teach and if anyone you're actually
going to be teaching it in Chicago
coming up this weekend this weekend
mm-hmm hopefully this gets out before
then if not people go and look you up
and it has all the whole schedule time
tell us now look
shake we know that how simple is this
process the the Islamic marriage high
what does it entail and how simple it is
well I mean when it comes to marriage
it's supposed to be easy
Allah so Jenna made it very simple and
very easy even if people study the thick
of getting married
in terms of establishing the commitment
establishing the contracts of the nikah
head so it's actually very simple how
long does it take a few seconds a job
and Kabul in terms of the actual
contract it's actually a job on Kabul so
there have to be that the the the the
groom the bride her wali her father in
this case for example or someone who
represents her and two witnesses and
when they speak in front of a rarity to
to establish the nikah the first person
says that I've given you my daughter
basically in America the one says I
accepted or unmarried
and even sure we're done this is that as
simple as that of course there's certain
technicalities in there but as simple as
that however to get to this point people
they need to be ready for it
that's what takes you actually want to
prepare the people for this point so in
terms of starting the Nika itself it's
very simple the preparation for it it
takes a while that's where people
unfortunately they complicate things so
what what are the qualification to get
to this point of getting married that's
what makes things very difficult for
many many people so for instance of the
common things these days is there the
financial burden to get to this point so
initiating the marriage it's no longer
as easy it used to be in the past it
costs people and I was surveying people
at this and for example in Chicago area
for instance they say an average is
about fifty thousand dollars for example
just to initiate the marriage contract
now not every every young man who barely
came out of college find a job now he
thinks he's ready for marriage can
afford for example fifty thousand that
means he's gonna have to negotiate that
with his parents and with his family not
every family is able and capable of
doing that so Finance is speaking it
actually becomes a huge burden on them
another thing some of the ladies
basically they wait for for themselves
to finish your education they want to
finish education but then education
doesn't have limits so they want to
finish bachelor's degree and then they
go to master's degree and they maybe
take another master's degree and so on
and they're waiting basically to for the
right person to come so they can maybe
make a commitment after that these
things these things are shifting our
focus the dynamics of marriage are
shifting and changing because of the
requirements people put on in order for
this point to come which is the H the
actual contract itself so father sees
his son Sons about about eight years old
he starts put mousse in his hair you
know he's a good kid and father's asking
his son he's like real surprise what's
going on here right and and he starts
asking him questions he made to start
talking about marriage she asked him so
one would you like to get married son
and the son thinks and he's like about
fourteen fifteen
so the point here is at what should
these conversations start with your
children at a young age and living in
the culture that we're in right right
now with a lot of the pitfalls that you
know young kids can fall into is it
better that if the child now grows to be
mature
at what age obviously after we passed
the legal age of marriage but now let's
say 18 19 20 early 20s is it encouraged
now that if the children really you know
the the instead of falling into the
haram that we make the hell out easy and
we start encouraging them you know to
get married what do you think on is the
key word that you mentioned yourself is
maturity so when it comes to age there's
of course there's a legal requirement as
we live in the society over here so we
have to abide by that yes and also some
ethical issue as well however
historically speaking in the life of
mankind whether it's a Muslim culture or
even a culture of other faiths as well
people that used to get married at a
very young age now what is exactly why
would they do that for today this would
could be considered you know a crime
perhaps but back then it was the norm
why is that because the level of
maturity coincided at that time with the
age of puberty because with the age of
puberty financial maturity also
coincides with that as well back then so
at age fourteen fifteen a young man at
that moment would not be considered a
minor he would be considered a man who's
already actually having a skill earning
money
capable of maybe running a household and
so forth that was back then today maybe
we're still very young at that age is
considered very young so what happened
is that we pushed the age of puberty I
mean the age of the maturity in general
to coincide with education so for us as
long as the person is still in school we
don't see the person who's still ready
for marriage so if he is 23 years old
still doing his bachelor's degree it's
very difficult very difficult for
parents to accept
giving their daughters and fall in a
relationship and Fullmer
still in school they might accept a
compromise and that is to have Danica
hard-on to have the the marriage
contract done but the actual wedding and
moving in together they might postpone
that until they both are ready to move
in together which is for them for the
man to finish his school you know
earnest start earning his money and
therefore the lady also to finish your
school as well that is now how people
actually get in this so when it comes to
age it really depends on the maturity
and maturity in two things will be
understanding responsibility of marriage
and number two is that the fact that
they know they know that they're the age
factor for them right now is legal as
well so once they have the maturity of
marriage and the responsibilities of
marriage are understood very well and
they display of course in their manners
and their lifestyle that they understand
that they'll be ready for marriage is
this alternative better now then because
you'll hear stories okay because when
you enter the atmosphere now the whole
culture you know where people go to the
universities for the experience yes and
now you get sucked into a lot of the
like I said the pitfalls but then you
hear of it's unfortunate even Muslims
will fall into you know zina and doing
really bad things that's the reality but
then someone will shine from the bunch
and you'll hear let's say a sister that
she's you know she's married and she's
still in university but they haven't
moved in together they did what you just
said that in Aqaba she's preserving
herself her chastity her morality is
this something really to consider for
parents who are out there because one
more thing shake we can many people can
see this who've grown up here but some
people are naive who they don't know the
culture some parents come from back home
and they really don't know what's going
on true you see when it comes to doing
doing this doing the nikah and delaying
that the wedding two years maybe one and
a half years in a year or even more than
that until their kids are ready for
marriage it's a compromise that parents
do in order to preserve the chastity of
their children and help their kids as
well you know do the right thing you
know I admire the parents I admire the
young ones who take that step to
preserve themselves and protect
themselves from falling into the haram
but as much as I would love for them to
proceed
that I personally say that this is would
be actually a case by case scenario case
by case I cannot give this as a blanket
you know answer for everybody because
not all young men and women are mature
enough to understand the meaning of that
you see most of these kids what they
want to really do they were just - holla
fire a dating experience for themselves
they want someone they go to the movies
with someone to eat ice cream with
someone just to hang out with that's
what they want unfortunately in many
many cases because they see their
friends were non-muslim they do these
things I don't see any problem with that
but for them because they know that the
the fear allah subhanho wa taala want to
do the right thing but at the same that
they don't want to wait any longer so
they try to do that so by doing so
unfortunately they they they're trying
to earn the pleasure and privilege the
marriage is providing for them without
acknowledging or assuming the
responsibility that marriage demands
from them that's the problem
so one two years being in a relationship
if they keep their word and commitment
of course not to consummate the marriage
until later that that that is great but
the pressure is so high so which is so
great on them so it is actually a good
arrangement again if the circumstances
are right and it's a case by case
scenario but the best way to do for
these young men and women honestly is to
speed up the process of finishing
education being in school doesn't mean
to delay your maturity they need to
study finish their school in the process
act on working on getting married
meaning they need to start acting like
that they need to start preparing
themselves for that psychologically
mentally even financially if possible in
any way that is possible for them we're
gonna be right back with more here on
the Deen show don't go anywhere please
subscribe to the diva follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show with my good friend
Shay Augusta good job thank you again
for being with us
Alfie Kohn and okay why do you feel now
look we know marriage obviously is half
of our Deen like I mentioned earlier
and it's something that is helping to
preserve your Islam and we look back in
history and it seemed like the marriages
were they were able to hold better
together but today they seem like this
deteriorating much quicker wises somehow
I mean I've been actually doing these
workshops and these surveys with a young
generation and I'm talking to students
and I'm as a camp you know I must say on
campuses and so forth so what I've seen
that there's certain trend that is
happening in the Muslim community back
in the days when it comes to marriage
people they understood the meaning of
commitment for them commitment is the
word for marriage today our generation
the younger generation growing up in
different culture that culture has
certain elements number one it provides
so much so much choice for them having
choice multiple choice a lot more than
what they expect the events so they
think that the variety gives them choice
they deserve that choice there is no
doubt about it but unfortunately they
don't make the right choice sometimes in
many cases so since they have options
they keep delaying because there is no
rush that's number one number two many
of the younger generation today live in
what I personally called the I join the
I generation because everything is about
iPhone iPad iTunes and then comes that I
know so basically it's the generation
that things that it knows everything and
as a result they don't that when it
comes to marriage it's one of the things
that unfortunately don't even try to
learn they don't even try to take a
course or even an education or training
actually therefore the thing that does
like it happened and worked for their
parents it must work for us as well and
then hence of course the project they
have because they don't have the proper
training for it
another thing about the generation lacks
one of the most
I personally believe the essential
qualities for successful relationship
and that is patience see the prophets
allah's I'm setting a mobile poverty
line while Maruti I had an aunt on and
fouled out Simon estaba that Allah
subhana WA that did not bestow anything
on anybody that is more beneficial and
is more valuable to a person than
patience this is the very that our
realization
failing to to to acquire and why because
they live in in the age of instant
gratification you see everything is
instant for them back in the day people
they had to stand in lines to get their
things done it used to take time to get
things done and so forth today
everything is instant you have
smartphones in your pocket that you get
everything done instantly you don't
stand in lines because you can do it
online everything is done a
drive-through instead of taking time to
go into the store and so on so as a
result the generation got used to it
everything is basically is easy so if
things are not done quickly that
provides instant gratification for them
they become irritated and they don't
really hold on together another thing
because of the availability of things in
this culture we stop believing and
fixing things if your shirt rips you
don't fix it anymore you just bring a
new one because it's easier and cheaper
if your form breaks you just replace it
with a new one because it's easier and
cheaper hence if your marriage breaks
you don't fix it because you can bring
another one because easier perhaps or
cheaper that's the perception so the
generation the values of marriage are
shifting and changing back in those days
their culture you know set the standards
for them so husband wife came to the
relationship would you know expectations
that they both they know what to expect
and what what they're getting or what
they're giving in in this generation the
expectation has been shattered and no
roof has been placed over their heads
left for them to negotiate that and when
they do they might not do the right
thing together shaykh hadith last the
final master said the mankind problem
how many peace be upon him Jose brother
to Jesus Moses Abraham they all came to
the same message worship the Creator not
the creation the guidance that brings
the light when people are in a pit of
darkness it shows the light so if people
can see straight and they can see really
what this life is about and really
focusing not on a temporary temporary -
temporal but the permanent Jenna so the
Prophet peace be upon him when he said
that this Jenna that's eternal is going
to be surrounded by the undesirable
things and the Hellfire will be
surrounded by you know the so now isn't
at the end of the day you have to decide
what you want do you want to have the
goal and ultimate prize this temporal
life or do you want Jenna and if
marriage is half your Deen you're gonna
get mature and you're gonna get serious
with it absolutely you see
and since marriages have our Deen
basically because I wanna have a view
your Deen is spirituality and also
living this life as one however some
people they're actually they miss
understanding this hadith as well as
this misunderstand the concept itself
thinking that if they're going into
fitna the best escape from this fitna is
getting married thinking that marriage
is just like a magic wand you know it
just fixes all the power all the
spiritual failure and problems instantly
so they try to they want to get married
and they make wrong choices why because
they're rushing into it and they just
want to get married so they don't fall
into the Haram you don't realize that if
they have a spiritual problem that's
between them and Allah Azza WA JAL and
their marital status is absolutely
irrelevant to it if you have a problem
with your salah if you have if you don't
wake up for Fechter on time if you can't
fast money than thursday if you can't
lower your gaze if this and there and so
on marriage is not gonna fix that
instantly for you it might help you
might give you leverage there's no doubt
about it
however it's not the thing that will fix
your spiritual failure if you have a
problem with that you have to do it the
right way this is between you and Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala so there is no doubt
that people need to think to to to
assist to help each other of course you
know do the right thing as much as
possible and when it comes to marriage
you have to approach it the proper way
as well I'm sure a lot about a katana
but again at the same time I don't want
people to make marriage as an escape
from a reality that they're living in so
if they feel that they have problems
spiritual problem they need to work on
these spiritual problems regardless of
they were married or not so that when
the time comes for them to get married
and Charlotte are hopefully they're
they're cute and they're good so that
goes with we back it up in the heart of
course the heart is already corrupt and
you jump into the mirror it's not gonna
fix the heart of course it's not gonna
fix it this manager doesn't fix the
heart for you yeah it's you by the will
of allah subhanho wa taala what your
were the good actions and good
intentions we'll fix that and also that
will work for you when you get married
as well so if you have a good heart now
you your focus is Jenna your focus is
the Deen and now someone comes to marry
your daughter or vice versa and you look
those good Dean and the good o'clock
then it should I mean the the component
should be therefore successful
absolutely answer Paulo if someone has
these these qualities it will show in
their in their in their deeds it will
show in their character it will show in
the community people they asked me when
do you see when denied one do I know
that I'm ready for marriage I said you
want people will know how is that I said
if you act like someone who's ready for
marriage they will see that but if
you're always acting like you know like
a responsible person regardless how much
you convince yourself you're ready for
it people they won't see that in you so
you need to act like someone who's
already actually there and and that's
when somebody becomes more responsible
what people look for in a spouse they
need that the good practice of the Dean
they want the good alot and manner they
want the responsibility the maturity you
need to acquire these regardless of your
marital status once you have it you will
shine among the crowd people they will
go and will see this is someone who's
ready for marriage and eventually you
will find someone there for you shake
we're out of time can you leave us with
something else that we could benefit
from for the person who's out there
struggling you know they have a good
heart and they really want to get
married but now maybe the companionship
their friends pulling them away from
marriage maybe they're starting having
cold feet right and and and and all
these doubts creeping into their minds
maybe if Hollywood Bollywood and all the
other distractions what advice do you
have for this panel I mean in this
situation there is no doubt as we said
earlier it all goes back again to your
heart so and this is something between
you and the last panel on what item when
it comes to life it's all full of
struggles and every every age group has
its own struggles the struggle of that
age groups pala is the fitna of trying
to have this sound companionship and if
you need to you need to very very
basically as much as possible you know
when this kind of fitna and going back
to a lhasa panel Motel as part of your
trials as much as possible how would you
do that first of all your heart you all
work on this I know so many people they
work on their eyes they work on their
you know on their deeds on their actions
and so forth but the last thing that
takes attention from them as their heart
it's very important that you watch
basically how your heart is reacting to
these things meaningful it would email
for that with the
with contentment and forego Trudeau from
allah subhana wa ta'ala what you need to
do is that you do your part some people
that think that they have to become
mashallah super religious in order to
protect themselves for the fitna no even
those who are religious they are go they
go into the fitna so how do you do that
always do your part and then be content
with the result that comes from Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala you see a lot as it
just says in the inserted or ha well a
software take or a book of a turban that
Allah will give you until you content
and not until you're happy
some of us they do so many things
expecting to be happy at the end at the
end of what they're doing but it's not
that what makes you really happy if
you're content with the result from
allah subhana wa ta'ala you'd become
normal you feel normal as a human being
but always targeting something
idealistic will always feel that you're
falling short all the time so be
reasonable do your best fill your heart
and shout out that i would a man with
faith would believe in allah so she'll
do the right thing as much as you can in
shuttle to Baraka with Allah whatever
comes as a result still a fitness Allah
trial from Allah Azza WA JAL you be
patient with that come back to Allah
subhana all the time may Allah protect
you and protect your families along
thank you very much they can look you up
we're now in Charlotte Allah is gonna be
actually in in Western Alaska Chicago
Lamaze and from there if they miss this
one they can go to they're gonna go to
Al Maghrib www.elllo.org inshallah and
they can see all the classes comes in on
their screen another love notes
love notes thank you so much Sarah peace
when were peace Salaam alaikum peace be
with you sir and thank you for tuning in
to the Deen show and I hope you got to
benefit and and one of the main things
that we leave off here and the Sheikh
had mentioned it so many times and we
talked about it was the heart and that
reminds me of the saying of the last of
an emotional problem Holly peace be upon
him who said that there is a morsel of
flesh in the body and and and if it's
sound then the whole body is sound
that's the heart so when we focus on the
heart and we give it what it needs and
needs it connection with its maker and
needs to be charged just like that
iPhone is char's that heart needs to be
charged with what with all of the things
that the Creator has prescribed for it
and then when you start living this way
of life not part time but full
time then the heart gets right and then
you start to not take Demi Moore or
Patrick Swayze and the ghosts and the
Hollywood and you start looking to them
for what love is
no you look to the best of example
sentimental kind of problem Hamid peace
be upon him and the mothers of the
believers his wives that's right and
that's how we're gonna be successful if
you have any doubts dial up the REC to
the one who created you and reach out to
those qualified enough to give you that
advice and we'll see you next time
subscribe if you haven't already to the
Deen show we'll see you next time and
sha Allah God will until then peace be
with you please subscribe to the dgo
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below